o no
[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español cada país tiene sus secretos
francia evidentemente tiene muchísimos y
hoy vamos a conocer uno de esos uno de
los mejor guardados de la república
francesa gracias al periodista marcelo
báez fresh se trata de una de las
secretos que han transcurrido durante
muchos años y que han sido escondidos a
la mayoría de la población francesa
marcelo best 3 bienvenido a esta escala
en parís
es usted autor del libro léger dance se
cree de la république el jardín secreto
de la república justamente un jardín que
vamos a descubrir con usted además es
usted periodista de le parisian y
especialista de política francesa
marcelo brevemente explíquenos sobre de
qué se trata ese jardín secreto que
usted gracias a la perseverancia ya
muchas horas de trabajo logró descubrir
el castillo de chambord es el castillo
más conocido en francia muy grande y
construido y reconstruido en el siglo 16
por françois pone y tiene un bosque
5000 hectáreas y en ese bosque hay una
parte muy grande que está será en la
cual el público no puede entrar y desde
hace más de 40 años
ahí se organizan partidas de caza
organizada por el estado francés con
empresarios políticos totalmente
secretas es eso que cuento en este libro
ya lo han comprendido ustedes el
castillo de chambord es el valle del
loira un lugar famoso a nivel mundial
lleno de castillos de la época del
renacimiento
dice usted afirmó usted en este texto
que le costó muchísimo trabajo lograr
acceder a archivos la presidencia
francesa no fue muy colaborativa que
dijéramos en este terreno es un lugar
donde la clave es el secreto si lo
invitan a usted se tiene y tiene que
guardar el secreto todo el secreto por
por las invitaciones quien va como éste
el ritual y fue muy difícil entrar en
ese mundo y poco a poco por inter vistas
por ganando la confianza de la gente me
explicaron lo que pasa hay que saber por
ejemplo que las fotografías están
prohibida
este lugar las listas de invitados
desaparecen curiosamente están muy bien
guardadas por lo que se puede lo que
pudimos saber ahora bien cuáles son unos
de esos personajes que han podido
asistir y cuál es el procedimiento que
se ha seguido o que se seguía para las
invitaciones de gente que de alguna u
otra manera o estando dentro del poder o
muy cerca del poder marcelo por ejemplo
el presidente del senado francés llegar
a la eba es un invitado regular en ese
tipo de partidas de casa el ex
presidente de la asamblea nacional el
club barcelonés socialista es también un
invitado hay ministros hay empresarios
hay políticos hay deportistas es mucha
gente cercana del poder pero también
gente de la oposición no de los extremos
pero de la oposición lo que permite que
cuando es la izquierda invitan a la
gente también de derecha cuando la
derecha está en el poder invitan a gente
de izquierda hay como una am
una red un poco secreta de gente
aficionada a la casa que se encuentran
ahí hablan obviamente de casa animales y
también de políticas una de las personas
que usted entrevistas dice no se trata
cuando vienen o no aquí no se trata de
pasar acuerdos pero sí de buscar
acercamiento para pasar posteriormente
esos acuerdos y en este terreno lo que
llamó mi atención en el libro está lleno
de muchísimas anécdotas bastante
interesantes son las más que otras es el
georges pompidou que inicia vamos a
decir esta práctica de cacería hay que
saber que son jabalíes que son siervos
que son faisán es perdices patos en fin
son miles de animales que regularmente
que son introducidos a esta reserva
secreta no de como usted dice más de
5.000 hectáreas y es a partir de la
firma o era a partir de la decisión de
la presidencia de la república que unos
y otros podrían ser invitados habla
usted de los personajes nacionales pero
también es un arma diplomática
totalmente esa la parte de la
investigación que me pareció la más
interesante es que por ejemplo
e invitan a militares ingleses para
hacer operaciones franceses ingleses se
va por ejemplo el que es el dirigente el
que la cabeza del ejército de tierra de
la gran bretaña si gente de altísimo
nivel y pasan 24 horas en este lugar
espectacular casan y los vínculos
después son muy fuertes y per permite
después cuando la esa misma gente se
habla por teléfono dos meses tres meses
después tienen una cosa que entre ellos
recuerdos que los unen puede haber
también diplomáticos funcionarios
europeos gente también de las familias
grandes familias de la realidad de
reflejarlos españa por ejemplo estuvo en
el 75 cuando era príncipe y que lo
invitó el presidente giscard está hay
que saber que hasta los años 2010 más o
menos las invitaciones eran organizadas
directamente por la presidencia de la
república
ahora es el castillo de chambord que
invita pero el poder político en el
ellis de él la presidencia francesa
siguen mirando lo que está pasando y
avisen cuando dice por favor inviten a
tal o tal personalidad al mismo tiempo
estas prácticas de casa no son un cierto
reflejo de la evolución de la política
francesa
georges pompidou estuvo muy comprometido
para desarrollar este proyecto y scar
disten como usted lo señalaba después
llega mi terrón y la cosa comienza a
cambiar y sobre todo con irak con
jacques chirac hay la situación cambia
ya no es esta reserva presidencial que
va a funcionar aunque sigue habiendo las
prácticas de casa lo que pasa hay una
tradición de casa en en francia que es
muy vieja con su apoyo que construyó
este castillo lo construyó ahí porque
era un lugar para cazar los presidentes
franceses después lo usaron porque les
gustaba cazar y para invitar gente pero
llega una evolución de la sociedad que
hace que los presidentes ya no cazan
desde fonso a mis hijos ya no cazan
guardaron el instrumento jacques chirac
y nicolas sarkozy ellos un momento
pensaron cerrar esas casas del estado
pero en realidad la cerraron
oficialmente pero siguieron usando ese
ese elemento que les permite hacer
relaciones públicas no no asumidas vamos
a decir para el listado hay una anécdota
un poco sanguinaria que usted cuenta que
es bastante que me llamó mucho la
atención es el año de 1970 93 perdón
cuando fueron invitados en el grupo de
seguridad de la presidencia de la
república es decir los guardaespaldas de
la presidencia de la república una
imagina los hombres que llegaron ahí se
había preparado precisamente los
animales para que fueran casados y eso
que en urgencia suspendieron dos
partidas una masacre impresionante los
datos son 932 faisanes asesinados o
muertos 21 patos 42 pero perdices
etcétera pero fue la primera y única vez
que pudieron entrar ahí lo que quiero
decir con esto es que además
no cualquiera puede repetir una aventura
y hay gente que fue invitado una sola
vez y después nunca más si ser invitado
es un privilegio hay que no hablar
derecho de que uno nos invitó hay que
respetar las reglas de seguridad y hay
que estar atento está ese es muy es un
muchacho se fue eso en hawai que es otro
castillo pero en la cual hay también
esas casas de la república y eso es
guardaespaldas de cada vez que pasaba un
faisán lo mataban y al final ancianos
quedaban animales y le dijeron bueno ahí
para mosto y es la primera y última vez
que hacemos una partida de casa
solamente para los guardaespaldas o sea
que estamos muy bien preparados pero hay
otras anécdotas que también llamada de
atención que es de los mejores que esté
el libro bastante interesante del jardín
secreto de la república estamos en
diciembre de 2007 nicolas sarkozy acaba
de ganar la presidencia y decide invitar
al dictador del libio mal libio manual
kadhafi para agradecerle la vibración de
las enfermeras entonces moamar kadafi es
invitado se prepara
los animales que el dictador debería de
cazar se liberaron dice usted 500 aves
faisanes que instalan el puesto de tiro
a kaddafi tira el primero y falla en el
segundo y falla y el equipo se enerva se
molesta cuéntenos usted lo que sucedió
después en ese momento él dice no yo
quiero mis armas armas automáticas pero
ese es un lugar para cazar faisanes
donde no se usan obviamente esos esas
armas y el después sale del lugar donde
está es que está prohibido que no tiene
que ir caminando aquí y se pone a usar
sus armas contra los faisanes que están
caminando porque son animales que
primero caminar y después hay que y
después solamente se ponen a volar y uno
normalmente casa cuando es un cazador
cuando están en el cielo y ahí tirada en
el suelo casi casi mata a un agente que
ayudas que para los animales y ahí bueno
es un es que los franceses miran eso y
dicen no qué está haciendo este señor
y termina diciendo ahí fue un momento
muy lindo por favor amigos franceses
organicen eso en trípoli capital y la
gente los grandes y si no eso fue por la
primera y última vez que hacemos desde
con él la situación ha cambiado
evidentemente en ambos hay una cosa que
usted comenta que es poco conocida este
comité guión dos y el motel guillermo
tell hay un lobby de 1.100.000 cazadores
en francia hay un millón cien mil
personas que tienen el permiso de lanzar
el permiso de cazar que lo que en europa
son en francés el primer lugar el primer
lugar se exactamente y es una asociación
vamos a decir unas federaciones muy
potentes muy bien organizada y con mucha
influencia en el poder político ahí lo
vistas muy cercana por ejemplo a emanuel
ma con un señor que se llama por ejemplo
tiene cost
hay un senador muy cercano también al
presidente que se llama fosa patria que
son
hay un vínculo muy fuerte en francia
entre ese es el mundo de la de la casa y
el poder político y especialmente con el
presidente actual en el maco allá este
propósito también han sido invitados
personajes por ejemplo de eeuu una cosa
que es poco sabido muy cercanos al lobby
de las armas en eeuu sí invitaron el la
meta de esas invitaciones no es tanto
diplomáticos innovación es recuperarme
plata dinero para el castillo hay por
ejemplo un americano
schvartzman los que dio más de tres
millones de dólares al castillo para
remodelar todos los jardines y este
señor para agradecer le dieron la
posibilidad de organizar dos partidas de
casa con 36 personas dos veces y hay que
ver lo que es no sólo es un el castillo
ahí una y un bosque espectacular sino
que hay cuando es una organización
impresión
ante con más de 100 personas que ayudan
a la organización de la partida de casa
ahí hay lo que se llama la guardia
republicana que se aguarda como decir de
la ciudad de la presidencia que está ahí
es un momento espectacular para la gente
que le gusta y que participa a esos
momentos bien pues las partidas de casa
presidencial fueron suspendidas pero en
la roma imperial predomina todavía allí
usted señora la conservan lo esencial
son la antecámara del poder estamos
llegando ya al final de este escala en
parís no me queda sino agradecer a
marcelo o braveheart el autor de ley
ardan cp de la república jardín secreto
de la república su presencia en nuestros
estudios gracias marcelo ustedes les
damos una nueva cita la próxima semana
en otra escala en parís
[Música]